[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing hogwarts slytherin
ravenclaw hufflepuff and gryffindor more
specifically we're going to be
discussing the darker side of the
wizarding world
in seeing which hogwarts houses other
than southern
produced dark witches and wizards
slytherins get a bad rap
they really do and they're commonly
painted with the same brush
all slytherins are evil this is
reinforced by hagrid in the
philosopher's stone
when he says there's not a single witch
or wizard who went bad
who wasn't in slytherin but in a video i
made just last week which i'll link down
below i proved that this isn't true
and was able to make a list of seven
slytherins that ended up
perfectly fine today's video will be
challenging hagrid's statement
once again however as it turns out not
only are there witches and wizards from
slytherin that turned out just fine
but there also happens to be a number of
witches and wizards from other houses
that went down a darker path
this video isn't going to be looking at
purely evil wizards
though i will include them but focusing
mainly on wizards that
just weren't good and made some
questionable moral decisions in their
lives
without further ado i present to you in
no particular order
five bad wizards that didn't come from
slytherin
number one peter pettigrew peter
pettigrew also known as wormtail
was a british pureblood wizard born in
or 1960. he had pale skin unhealthy hair
that was constantly falling out
and blue eyes it was a sniveling excuse
for a man
whose loyalties only lay where there was
power and he did not value friendship or
love
in the way that most do pettigrew
started at hogwarts in the year 1971
the same year that sirius black remus
lupin and
james potter began attending the school
the quartet of boys would eventually
form a group
called the marauders one thing that they
had in common was that they were all
gryffindors
however that turned out to be all the
pettigrew had in common
the other three boys as over time he
proved to be quite different
the problem with pettigrew was that he
didn't have his own identity
he just mirrored those around him his
character was exceptionally weak
and this is what led to him being
convinced to join voldemort
unconvinced that the good guys would
prevail pettigrew turned his back on
everyone that was close to him
and in one massive act of cowardice
exposed the location of the potter
cottage to voldemort
pettigrew is perhaps the best and most
extreme example
of someone from another house going bad
number two
quirrell quironese quirrell was an
english half-blood wizard
born sometime in the 1960s when he was
of age he began attending hogwarts
school of witchcraft and wizardry
at which point he was sorted into
ravenclaw house quirrell certainly
didn't start off all bad
in fact he was initially a meek natured
boy that simply focused on his school
however coral who was also highly
unusual and delicate
was teased profusely at school making
the anxious quirrell
even more anxious his feelings of
inadequacy
led to him taking a particular interest
in the dark arts
a highly complicated and dangerous field
of magic that could perhaps garner
quirrell the intention
and respect that he always longed for
for the duration of his studies he
showed a particular affinity for the
dark arts
and he ended up graduating from hogwarts
with impressive grades across the board
it was at this point that he was able to
secure her job as muggle studies
professor at hogwarts
in the year 1990 quirrell took a
year-long sabbatical
he told his peers that the sabbatical
was an opportunity for him to gain
first-hand experience in the field where
in reality his objective was to find
lord voldemort
exceedingly curious about what had
happened to the dark lord who tyrannized
the wizarding world for years on
end and fine voldemort he did however
things didn't go
exactly according to plan voldemort
recounts his first meeting
with quirrell a wizard young foolish and
gullible
wandered across my path in the forest i
had made my home
oh he seemed the very chance i'd been
dreaming of
for he was a teacher at dumbledore's
school he was easy to bend to my will
he brought me back to this country and
after a while
i took possession of his body to
supervise him closely as he carried out
my orders
quirrell's lack of confidence and his
neurotic nature led to him being easily
manipulated by voldemort
and though querrell didn't necessarily
have to end up being bad
he certainly did number three lockhart
let me start off by saying that lockhart
is a bit of a unique case
he wasn't evil per se but he was greedy
and ambitious
which led to him performing some
questionable acts in his life
gilderoy lockhart was a british
half-blood wizard born in the year 1964
to a witch mother and muggle father his
parents
had two other children two girls but
lockhart proved to be the only one that
was magical
which whether she would admit it or not
made him his mother's favorite child
lockhart was a clever good-looking boy
and when he realized quite early on that
he was magical
it only went to his head and inflated
his already massive ego
even further in 1975 lockhart began
attending
hogwarts school of witchcraft and
wizardry where he was sorted into
ravenclaw house
when he first walked through the doors
of the school he was met with
disappointment
as he came to the crushing realization
that at a school for witches and wizards
he was just another magical young boy in
the muggle world
gilderoy was exceptional but here he
didn't stand out
and that's all he ever longed for it's
been expressed that as a young boy
lockhart did possess slightly above
average abilities
but nothing particularly noteworthy and
his lack of attention
only fueled the fire inside of him to be
successful
however the success that lockhart found
and achieved in his life
was certainly not deserved he became
famous by stealing the accomplishments
of others
by wiping their memories and then
claiming those accomplishments
as his own this morally questionable
behavior
though not necessarily evil is certainly
horrific
and i don't think that he ever properly
considered the ramifications of his
actions
similar to quirrell lockhart felt
inadequate and it's primarily for this
reason
that he was laid down a darker path
number four
barty crouch jr let me start off by
saying that barty crouch junior's house
isn't actually confirmed
while many have been quick to plot him
into slytherin due to his obvious evil
nature
and association with the death eaters i
think that they're neglecting to
properly look at his past
marty crouch jr was a british pureblood
wizard and the son of ministry of magic
official
martinez crouch senior crouch jr has a
rich history with the death eaters
and joined them in his teenage years
throughout his life he certainly
committed
many atrocities including helping to
torch the long bottoms
murdering countless witches and wizards
and playing an instrumental role
in voldemort's resurgence however there
is another dimension to crouch's
character that is often overlooked
his intelligence a trait which is most
closely associated with ravenclaw house
he was really really talented and before
turning over to the dark side
actually gained 12 owls while studying
at hogwarts
to put this into perspective hermione
only gained
10. though we can't say for sure that
crouch junior wasn't
a sudden i think there is a strong case
to be made for him being a ravenclaw
as far as dark wizards come body crouch
jr was pretty bad
number five young dumbledore that's
right
dumbledore however not the old wise
dumbledore that we're used to
but instead the young foolish dumbledore
the dumbledore that was heavily
influenced by gelat grindelwald
the dumbledore that operated along with
grindelwald
under the slogan for the greater good in
the deathly hallows we learned
dumbledore
and gelit grindelwald in their early
years plotted wizard dominion over
muggles
this is when they first came up with
their slogan and this was also when
their plan was effectively
to become rulers over muggles dictators
before actually acting in accordance
with this slogan however
dumbledore abandoned the idea and
eventually confronted his friend
gelet grindelwald what likely prompted
dumbledore's change of heart
was his sister getting killed after a
three-way jewel
involving aberforth dumbledore and
grindelwald
though dumbledore eventually became good
who's to say that
if his sister hadn't been killed
dumbledore wouldn't be ruling over
muggles to this very day
and that's it for this video do you guys
agree with this list
am i missing someone let me know in the
comment section
below until next time you're a wizard
harry
[Music]
you